there's a part of the movie and I don't
think it's giving away too much where
the crew has to survive for a long
period of time with no food they were
adrift too eventually you know about 90
days about 90 days they're there they
have they have they have to live on
these incredibly small rations so you
needed the actors I was watching the
movie and I was thinking how did you get
these actors I mean Chris Hemsworth
looks skeletal and I thought you can't
do that with CGI what's what how did you
do this you don't feed him Conan you
just but they're not zoo animals you
Kevin a minute jail nutritionists
trainers you know cooks there to make
sure that the the tiny little caloric
intake that they have is you know power
food and super how many calories a day
well ultimately down to about 500
calories a day you know hundred calories
a day I mean there's snack that would
come out that they would be just
ravenous for would be like seriously
like a slice of cucumber a little olive
oil with an almond on top and they'd be
give me the almond almond Wow okay well
here this raises an interesting question
these actors are literally starving in
front of you right for a lengthy period
of time while you shoot this film right
how would what about the crew is the
crew uh well eating food in front of
them for their their you know they're
you know they're highly respectful of
what these guys are doing these guys are
trying to recreate you know something
with authenticity they're committing
themselves but every once in a while I
would be standing there talking about a
scene and I just see rage in their eyes
I thought they were mad at me and then I
would turn around and some guy was
eating a freaking sausage sandwich right
I have to I'd give that in a look I'd
have to give that guy that look guys
like you guys are doing a great job
I did I'm not even gonna finish this but
when they were adrift at sea of course
and we were we were working with cameras
further away at times and they were
alone out there for hours and you know
acting they had their dialog moments
they had their their dramatic scenes but
when I would yell cut I would have my
earphones on and I could still you know
I can still hear what they were saying
it would go instantly to foodporn yeah
it was just you know you know wait have
you have you had it have you been to
America and I had a Krispy Kreme mate
yeah you know yeah Pizza yeah people
they because when you're that hungry
that's all you can obsess on and then I
did talk about food up till the moment
that I was saying okay we're get ready
to roll and then they were back to 1820
and maybe and no food and Chris
Hemsworth actually was named 2014
sexiest man alive yeah I think but by
People magazine while you were shooting
and you guys took a picture of him the
day the announcement came out and he
certainly doesn't look like it was good
my god it was he looks like that thing
you used to clean a cannon yeah you know
it you know he's very dedicated they all
are and and they all followed Chris's uh
you know example and leadership and and
and you know you are you are recounting
these real events a lot of them are very
emotional yes very surprising they
relate to our world in ways that kind of
you know I think surprised me when I
first read it and it's also a chance to
make you know a movie that that kind of
scope and scale hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please